est-ce que vous avez des nouvelles des
résultats de vos camarades écologistes
dans les circonscriptions
écoutez nous de toute façon les
écologistes il ya une semaine ou quinze
jours je disais nous avons au mieux
certainement quatre élus ce qui est fait
puisque nous étions dix pendant cette
mandature mais nous pouvons penser que
ces quatre seront réellement la semaine
prochaine puisque on a des nouvelles
positives d'esther benbassa à paris de
ronan dantec dans le 44 de joël labbé
dans le morbihan et dans l'isère
guillaume ronsard qui est un maire
écologiste a de bonnes chances de
l'emporter face ce ne sont pas
évidemment des chiffres définitifs mais
des tendances ce sont des tendances
générales sur les premières centaines
dépouillé donc on n'a pas encore les
chiffres définitifs donc on peut pas
dire c'est sûr à 100% mais ce sont quand
même des tendances une dynamique et donc
c'est plutôt positif que nous ayons
parmi ceux et celles qui étaient pause
qui avaient la possibilité de l'emporter
bac effectivement elle le fasse dont
vous nous confirmer qu'il y aura bien
des écologistes des élus écologistes
ici au sénat pour la prochaine mandature
voilà je vous confirme qu'il y aura des
élus écologistes pour la prochaine
mandature
j'espère que ce sera au minimum 4 et
après ça donne pas la possibilité de
faire un groupe mais j'imagine que la
semaine prochaine il y aura des contacts
seront pris avec les nouveaux élus pour
essayer de faire un groupe encore une
question jean désessard vous avez été
l'une des figures de cette mandature qui
s'achève
puisque vous ne vous êtes pas candidat
au renouvellement de votre mandat dans
quel état d'esprit vous êtes sous cette
salle des conférences aujourd'hui
positive parce que je trouve que
l'atmosphère ici est plutôt réussi je
crois que le sénat bien organisée le
dépouillement
les la collecte des résultats je pense
que les journalistes sont nombreux donc
ça c'est plutôt positif donc ça
participe à la transformation de l'image
du cénacle souhaite non seulement le
président du sénat mais l'ensemble des
groupes politiques
donc je quitte le sénat après 13 années
de travail d'un temps